오늘은 그 일본에 좀 일정이 있어
가지고 한 1박 2일 일정으로 일본을
갈 예정입니다 일본 중에서 도쿄로 갈
예정이고 현지 부동산 업체도 좀
만나서 인터뷰도 간단히 좀 할
예정이고 그리고 이제 매물들도 좀
같이 본 다음에 일본 부동산 얘기를
요즘에 너무 많이 들어서 직접 가서
한번 좀 봐야겠다라는 생각이 좀 많이
들어서 좀 이렇게 어 일박이 일정으로
좀 일정을 잡았습니다 사람이 너무
많습니다 제가 지금 새벽 5시 왔는데
해외 여행 진짜 많이 가는 거 같아요
그리고 최근에 또 해외 여행을 또
많이 오기도 하고 우리나라로 요즘에
뭐 홍대나 명동 다시 좀 살아났고
강남만 보더라도 외국인들이 굉장히 좀
많아졌습니다 관광객들이 와서 소비도
하고 그래서 상권이 좀 더 업그레이드
되는 거 같거든요 아 공항선으로 좀
접해 있는 그런 상권 인근에는 확실히
좀 좋은 효과는 있지 않을까 생각이
됩니다 앞으로 좀 더 많이 오지
않을까 어 이렇게 예상하고
있습니다
일단 고객분이 이쪽 인근에 맨션을 좀
찾는다 그래서 저가 좀 알아보다가 아
뭐 직접 가서 봐야겠다라고 해가지고
일본에 좀 오게 됐고 그 맨션이
금액이 한 100억이 넘어요 일단 돈
있어도 살 수가 없대요 이미 완판이
됐고 매물이 나와도 그 특정 부동산
통해서만 살 수 있다 그래서 아니
과연 이게 뭔데 그렇게 이게
100억이 넘는데도 이렇게 할 사람이
많을까 지금 일본 부동산 시장이 좀
어떤가 되게 궁금하기도 해 가지고 좀
이렇게 일본에 오게 됐습니다 일단
지금 애나가 너무 좋고 어
투자하기에는 좀 굉장히 좀 좋은 시장
아닐까 최소 2 3년 정도는 좋지
않을까 좀 이렇게 조심스럽게 예상을
합니다 그래서 원래 비거주자는 어
대출이 안 나오긴 하지만 방법이
있거든요 그리고 지금 우리나라에 있는
그 은행 중에 이제 일본에 진출해
있는 은행이 있어요 그래서 거기
통해서 어 법인 설립도 하고 좀
절차만 따르면 어 은행의 그 낮은
금리로 대출을 받을 수 있기 때문에
우리나라 사람들도 좀 투자할 수 있는
그런 길이 있는 거 같아요 우리나라
사람이 좀 만약에 투자한다고 했을 때
어떤 방식으로 투자할 수 있는지 어
그런 것도 잘 들어보고 좀 배워
보도록 하겠습니다 지금 또 이제 현지
일본 중개사 분을 좀 만나러 가서
뭐이 얘기도 좀 하고 아니면 좀
일본분 입장에서 좀 어떻게 생각하는지
그런 것도 좀 들어보면 좋을 거
같아서 유튜브 촬영이 안 된다 그래서
그 제가 듣고서 정리해서
말씀드릴게요네 가시죠 아무래도 여기가
이제 실제로 현업에 있는 업체다
보니까 그런 생생한 어 이야기들을 좀
많이 전달해 준 거 같습니다 굉장히
지금 도쿄에서 워낙 잘하고 있는
회사고 도쿄만 아니라 지금 일본
저녁으로도 좀 지점이 되게 많더라고요
그다음에 한국 사람에 대한 인식이
되게 좋더라고요 본인도 이제 한국어
되게 배우고 싶다고 자주 와서 이렇게
좀 보면 좋을 것 같습니다 위치나
이런 거에 따라 다르긴 하겠지만
가격이 막 그렇게 월등이 비싸거나
그런 거 같진 않아요 오피스가 지금
시장은 좋지 않은 거 같아요 어 전에
이제 코로나 이후에 일본 도 이런
재택 근무가 좀 많아진 거 같고
오히려 저희한테는 이런 맨션을 좀
많이 얘기를 하시더라고요 크로스 체크
하니까 거에 대한 수요는 꽤 있는 거
같더라고 법인을 좀 많이 추천을
했어요 개인은 우리랑 똑같이 세금이
더 높다고 합니다 법인은
세율적용 따라 다르긴 하겠지만 한 뭐
매매 가격에 한 5 60% 정도
나온다 그러고 진짜 괜찮은 건 뭐
70% 그 이상 뭐 이렇게 얘기를
하더라고요 회사로 문의를 주시면
저희가 이쪽 업체에 컨택을 해서
매물을 실제로 좀 받아 볼 거예요
일단은 뇌물은 한국돈으로 한
10억에서 50억 뭐이 정도 사이도
꽤 많이 있는 거 같더라고요 그거를
한번 만약에 찾으신다고 하면 연락
주시면은 저희가 컨택해서 한번 좀
자료도 받을 수 있도록 도와드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다 그다음에 긴자에
대한 내용 상권에 대해서도 한번 좀
소개해 드리도록 하겠습니다 가시죠
먼저 소개해 드릴 건물은 긴자식스
건물인데요 일본의 모더니즘을 대표하는
건축가 단위 구치 요시 오가 설계를
했고 지하 6층에 지상 13층 규모로
높이는 약 56m 최대 규모의
쇼핑몰입니다 상업 시설과 사무실 등의
면적을 합친 연면적은 약 한 15만
제미로 긴자 지역에서 최대 규모를
자랑합니다 이곳에 입점한 약
250개의 매장 중 120여개가 해당
브랜드의 본점이라고 하고 일본에서
유명한 서점인 츠타야 서점 그리고
스타벅스 리저브가 자리하고 있어
이곳을 방문해야 하는 뭔가 특별하
주을 그런 건물이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 전통문화 브랜드들이 밀접 어
있는 도쿄의 상징적인 긴제 거리를
소개해 드리겠습니다 세계적인 고급
상점과 백화점 골동품점 번화가 등이
밀집되어 있고 교통편도 역세권에
위치하고 있고 긴자 메인 스트리 진
긴자 거리에는 평일에는 끊임없이 줄을
지어 차량이 진입하지만 주말과
공유일에는 차량 진입이 금지되어
있습니다 그래서 유동 인구가 굉장히
많은 곳이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
긴자 플레이스는 흰색 일색의 외벽으로
둘려싸여 있고 꽃바구니 이나 향로로
자주 사용하는 투족 기법에서 영감을
얻어
5315 장의 알루미늄 패널의
격자형으로 배열이 되어 있습니다 닉산
자동차와 소니의 기아의 쇼룸에 있는이
빌딩은 11층 건물로 2016년
9월에 준공되었습니다 긴자 4초에
있는 야마노 약기 긴자 본점은 일본
국토교통성이 발표한 2023년
공시지가에 따르면 주택지와 상업지
등에 합한 전체 용지의 정 중국 평균
땅값이 작년보다 1.6% 오은
가격으로 무려 평당 17억 5천만
원의 최고가를 찍었다고 합니다 약간
여기 느낌은 좀 신세계 본정 그런
뭔가 느낌이 나고 제일 좀 화려한
그런 거리인 거 같고 무엇보다 이제
공실 이런게 좀 없어요 이렇게 고층
건물인데 한 브랜드로 꽉 채어 들어가
있는 그런 이쁜 건물들이 너무 많았고
걷기가 좋은 그런 도로인 거 같습니다
내일 이제 또 다시 만나서 그때는
이제 인터뷰도 좀 하고 그다음에 매물
나와 있는 것도 좀 보고 촬영을 좀
해보도록 하겠습니다 식사하고 좀
숙소가서 좀 쉬야 될 것 같아요 지금
너무 피곤해 가지고 그러면 영상은
이만
[음악]
마무리하겠습니다